Percy was meaningful not was this
expedient you arrived in the book there
is no faith and no courage and no
sacrifice in doing what is expedient
what do you say to those viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and are locked
into their careers because they are too
afraid to take risks and pursue
something meaningful well the first
thing I would say is well you should be
afraid of taking risks and pursuing
something meaningful but you should be
more afraid of staying where you are if
it's making you miserable
it's like the first thing you want to do
is dispense with the idea that you get
to have any any permanent security
outside of your ability to contend and
adapt it's the same issue with children
it's like you're paying a price by
sitting there being miserable and you
might say well the devil I know is
better than the one I don't it's like
don't be so sure of that the clock is
ticking yeah and if you're miserable in
your job now and you change nothing in
five years you'll be much more miserable
and you'll be a lot older but this into
the luxury to push you what is
meaningful our viewers have mortgages
they have children yeah they have
payments and loans it's a luxury to
pursue because we lack the resources
well I don't think I don't remember now
I'm not talking about what makes you
happy it's a luxury to pursue what makes
you happy it's a moral obligation to
pursue what you find meaningful and that
doesn't mean it's easy it might require
sacrifice if you need to change your job
to let's say you have family and and and
and children and a mortgage you have
responsibilities you've already picked
up those responsibilities you don't just
get to walk away scot-free and say well
I don't like my job I quit
that's no strategy but what you might
have to do is you think well this job is
killing my soul all right so what do I
have to do about that well I have to
look for another job well no one wants
to hire me it's like okay maybe you need
to educate yourself more maybe you need
to update your your curriculum vitae
your resume maybe you need to overcome
your fear of being interviewed maybe you
need to sharpen your social skills like
you you have to think about these things
strategically if you're going to switch
careers you have to do it like an
intelligent responsible person that
might take you a cup
of years of of effort to do properly
when you say pursue something meaningful
is it important to have a vocation I
think it's more important to to have a
an ethos an ethic so I have a program
for example called the Future authoring
program which is an writing program that
enables people to develop a vision for
their life and then to develop a
strategy and so it's based on the idea
imagine that and it's an extension of
the ideas in the book or at least
something along the same lines the first
thing that you want to do is figure out
imagine you were taking care of yourself
like you were someone you cared for
which is rule number 2 by the way
essentially then you should figure out
well if you could have what you needed
and wanted what would it be what sort of
friends would you have what would your
family relationships look like how would
you conduct yourself with your children
how would you educate yourself you need
to think through how it is that your
life could be properly arranged if you
had that ability and then you can aim at
that and the funny thing is is that if
you do pause it a goal of that sort and
work towards it you will move towards it
the goal will change because you'll
learn things along the way but I mean
I've dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and consulting practice and we
set a goal we develop a vision and work
towards it and it things inevitably get
better for people so it's not a luxury
it's it's difficult it's a moral
responsibility and it isn't happiness
it's it's not the pursuit isn't for
happiness it's a moral responsibility to
pursue what is meaning absolutely